good morning everyone today we'll be
reviewing the extension one trial and I
was in charge of marking question three
yes is there a question over there
excuse me sir
why don't those two hallmarks to this
question I think my answer just has more
marks than what I got well if you pay
attention to the marking criteria you'll
see that there was one mark for
differentiating and the other mark was
yeah I can see that but I made the same
mistake in last term's exam and I wasn't
marked so harshly then okay so that may
be because a different teacher is
marking that section then they may have
thought that you but that's not fair if
one teacher says one thing and another
teacher says something completely
different
how am I supposed to know what to expect
we do try to be as consistent as
possible and if you look at the number
of marks devoted to each question and
adjust your working out to reflect that
in the hopefully your - yeah but my
teacher says this method is totally fine
and my dad is a lawyer so I'm really
straight to the principal I don't
complain about you because obviously you
have no idea how to teach matter it's
all thing is ridiculous couple of tries
well if anyone needs me I'll just be at
my desk crying okay so what was all that
about before I explain let me first do
something which I never thought I would
do on one of these videos which is give
a big shout-out to Michael and Laura who
are the first people I've ever met
who've known me first from my videos and
then have met me in real life afterwards
I think for a memory we're making the
letters m and w with our fingers to
stand for mr. woo which feels really
silly now but I guess that's not
important it was really cool meeting you
guys I hope you do really well in your
subjects and I'm looking forward
actually to meeting lots more of you who
watch these videos and have been helped
by the lessons now the reason why I
wanted to start by talking about these
guys is because it's actually something
that one of them said which caught me
off guard at the time but has made me
really think afterwards and I think I've
had an epiphany that I wanted to share
with you all right so what one of them
said Laura actually was that she'd been
watching my teaching videos and saw a
lesson that I gave and had adopted one
of the methods for setting out or
solving a problem that I had taught in
my class and when she had used
that method or setting out in her own
school in her one of her exams
she lost half a mark or a mark or
something like that and I realized that
okay number one there's actually quite a
lot of people who are not in but the
school that I teach and not even in the
country where I live who are watching
these videos and learning the methods
that I'm teaching and it might not apply
you know the ways that I'm saying you
should approach this question or you
should write out your solution
I might not apply it to other people
that's the first thing and secondly I
realized that even within my own school
over a course of time and with other
different people this kind of phenomenon
happens you know that dialogue before is
something that's happened to me at least
you know on many different occasions all
rolled into one that's not that far from
reality of conversations that I've had
with students you've been saying why do
I get marked down for this or that and
people preempt that in class these days
and as I'm teaching something they'll
say well okay look what do I really need
to know or what do I really have to
write out to make sure that I get full
marks and that's a bit frustrating for
me that's a bit sad because I'm a
teacher I'm all about understanding
stuff right I'm not about okay here's
how you can perform best in any gym I
mean that's that's kind of nice as well
when you perform will it meet you but
hopefully that's a reflection of
understanding that you've gained in
class and that you get this subject or
or this topic or whatever so it's sad
firstly that people are getting marked
down for learning one kind of method but
someone else thinks it's invalid so you
mark down and secondly that we're
getting this fixation on okay how
exactly should I set it out you know I
understand this type of question or this
topic or this subject but what I really
need to know is is you know a cow we're
gonna set it out so that I make sure I
get full marks know before I do explain
the Epiphany that I had I want to share
a story from a parent-teacher night a
years ago when I maybe in the first or
second year that I okay I started
teaching and it was from a parent and he
was explaining the reason why he
encouraging his daughter to really try
hard in maths and to put a lot of effort
into it and his words were the reason
why Matt's is really good that you
should focus on that it's because unlike
say in humanities or in creative
subjects in maths you can know that you
can get a hundred percent on an exam the
humanities subject we're writing an
essay you know there might be like a
marking rubric that they give you but
there's always sort of a range of marks
you know this kind of response deserves
eighteen to twenty marks okay and so
what's the difference in eighteen
nineteen and twenty
there's not a clearly defined line
that's the nature of humanities and
creative subjects are the same because
you know what you think is a a really
good play or a really good short story
or website or design of whatever kind
might not match what someone else thinks
is a really really good work or effort
so you can never be confident that you
know you'll get a hundred percent and I
can imagine as an art teacher
you know seeing say a canvas in front of
me I can say well this is amazing but
I'd be really in sometimes reluctant to
say yeah that's a 100 percent kind of
painting right because when you say a
hundred percent there's a connotation of
it's perfect
it can't be improved any more this is
this is it right and I'm not a creative
time but I know that with designs and
with art you can always work on
something and and change it and adjust
it and make it better or depending on
how you define better which is part of
the problem so I thought to myself okay
is that right was that parent that
father was he right and you know
increasingly these days I find that he's
not because back in you know even in
primary school these days but if you go
back 20 years this is even more the case
mathematics where you got marks was for
the right answer okay there's this long
difficult problem and if you can do all
the right steps and get the right answer
at the end then tick that's it you've
got you've got it correct
okay the only way to get the right
answer is to use valid methods right how
can you calculate the height of this
tree or the angle of inclination or
whatever okay but over the last few
years I mean this is at least been since
the time that I've been in school but it
seems like it's become more and more an
emphasis
it's not so much about the final answer
even though obviously that's important
it's also that the process that you use
to get to that answer right and so I
think this is kind of the the reason why
people will see a right answer but as
teachers or markers Assessors they'll
give it different marks what marks are
awarded for these days is not just your
ability to get the right answer but to
demonstrate that you understand how to
get the right answer and to demonstrate
that you understand the problem and the
right way to solve it to demonstrate
that you understand the nature of what
you're trying to solve and you use a
valid approach use perhaps the most
elegant approach or succinct approach or
one that'll actually give you the right
answer for the right reasons right now
you can see this kind of an issue there
right because how do you assess
someone's understanding right how can
you say yeah I can tell this person
knows what they're talking about because
you can get the right answer but you can
get it in wrong ways right and I think
that's why there's so much emphasis on
working these days okay so as a teacher
let me give you an example if I was
looking at someone's general solution
for a treat problem okay I'm not just
gonna be looking at all right do they
get the right expression right at the
end for all of the values of x that will
solve this equation okay
I'm gonna look at all the steps for how
they went through and I'm gonna be
trying to determine right do they
understand what kind of function this is
do they understand how to test the
solutions that they end up with do they
understand how to take two general
solutions which look different and
actually combine them into one form all
of that I can't tell just by looking at
their final line I have to look at their
working okay but the way that I
can tell okay this person understands
something may be different from what
someone else expects right and this kind
of gets at the whole argument of alright
should we use abbreviations how much
kind of working is expected well if what
you're looking for is understanding and
you're trying to assess how much someone
gets something okay that is subjective
kind of like the creative subjects and
the humanities that we were talking
about before so mathematics has always
been like this but now it's being
assessed a different way now here's the
clincher okay most people when they hear
this they're like well that sucks you
know I want to be able to get to the
right answer and whichever way I got it
if it's a mess or if it's really short
or if there's no work you know I ought
to be able to get there right but
actually this way of marking I think I'm
convinced is way better than the
previous way okay because what's the
alternative well if if all of the
emphasis and all of the marks I devoted
just to your final answer did you get it
right
irrespective of how much working do you
take did you take shortcuts did you
abbreviate stuff that kind of thing if
all your emphasis is there then if you
get the final answer wrong then well you
know just have anything because you
didn't get the final answer and that's
where all the emphasis is okay whereas
if there is kind of attention paid to
well how did you go about it
were you close did you at least partly
understand it even if you didn't
understand it enough to get exactly the
right answer at the end then that makes
a whole lot of work for the marker
because we've got to read through
sometimes really really long answers but
it rewards people who aren't right at
the top and don't have a complete
understanding of things sort of still
get stuff but not enough to get it
exactly right so it's all these people
out there who maybe are watching the way
that I explain or watching the way
anyone else explains you know there's
plenty of maths or technology viewers
out there on the Internet
be careful do listen to what your
teachers say but more importantly don't
get frustrated try not to get frustrated
about the fact that things get marked
slightly subjective ways because us
teachers we're trying our best to test
how well you understand stuff not just
how well you can get to the final answer
okay so good luck to people in the
future particularly if you're you're
that kind of person who can't get it
perfectly right
i-i-i know I struggled a lot both in
high school and at university in order
let's do my subjects and to be honest I
relied on the fact that I could get a
sort of okay understanding of questions
and be rewarded for that even if I
didn't even have the the perfect highest
level understand that could get to the
right answer at the end I could get
somewhere and that was awarded that was
a that was merited with with marks that
I did deserve okay so I hope you guys
appreciate that realize he teaches a
trying their best and their doesn't get
you too frustrated